now what did you say about getting your
lips done now not my lips my eyelids all
that you live in this little it watch
lid lips why would I get my lids Lily
have an upper lip I have beautiful
sultry lips bottom lips fantastic I have
a nice upper lip is a little gun are you
[ __ ] kidding you know that's because
I have a moustache no I if I was gone
alright the whole my upper lip is like a
whole lot don't be a dick watch let me
just be relaxed with my mouth right nope
not really there your bottom ones pop in
papa
thanks buddy that's a fun thing to kiss
my bottom is a nice nice one of my
favorite is Brenda in the first time he
was started hanging out in Hollywood we
were at this party with a lot of
la-dee-da people you know and yeah you
know kind of some famous people and it
was a cool group and Brennan was still
kind of he was still fighting all these
musicians and actors and writers and and
I see Brennan standing there with his
legs really spread apart oh he's talking
he's trying to talk and he comes up to
me and he we're on a roof and he goes
hey I mean North oh yes all that party
to time dude I mean hey relative went to
that screening and well your anger
doesn't suck am i right it was all oh my
god - huge directors yeah that seemed
better via doing that definitely never
say like what do you think I'm moving
seemed better I mean just bigger than
everybody like well no you don't mean
like that do you mean like no no I mean
I was like no I definitely mean I've
seen better films than that huh just I
don't know how we're huge guy the first
time you barely tell me you got in a
pool is a pool party nobody swims had a
buddy in Los Angeles you [ __ ] Aurora
mousse the Aurora mousse is like Adam
all you get is like and he's like look
at my shoulders got bad tattoos fangirl
yoga scott is so big
no she goes ah he's so big I got the
water zone I started eating the mini ham
sandwiches ah whatever
I know he used to be so fine these two
really hot famous girls I won't say
their names they're looking at Brennan
he had a [ __ ] tank that I'm wearing
Jelena take away in there [ __ ] hungry
eye and the Giant and I go you those
girls are looking at you dude because I
know I know it's a curse and he's got
two slices of pizza my favorite uh could
I get a box I don't think I'm fat and he
puts it away like it like a girl and
then you who then you wait until they
left it order the apple pie he's an
apple pies the best now I've embraced
the thickness it was great I have
embraced the thing why you wouldn't I'd
be [ __ ] all over it it's all I've
ever wanted to be they like first is a
sad one a cured died it was so much
older than I thought I wear with him I
work with Fred a couple times let it be
um came remember honestly lunch stuff
yeah he was just so funny
well I remember him and uh so good in
the [ __ ] you know got was it Everybody
Loves Raymond no I didn't want to not
really nobody watch that stuff Ron
Burgundy oh man yeah boss and increment
we're gonna let you go so funny yeah
cause of death hasn't been determined
yet when I was was 86 oh I can imagine
number including gharana yeah they might
check it was grown yeah wow what a
Korea's got Marc Maron's lifetime or
nothing mm-hmm Marc Maron what didn't
get that when this happen uh yeah Marc
Maron's girlfriend died Oh God and he
talked about on the podcast he's I don't
know what else to do this I'd deal with
grieving
I can't believe know me as this um yeah
so he yes she died she had a rare blood
disorder and he said she thought yet
reps strep throat yeah so she got that
taken care of and then he chews at his
house and she went to go to the bathroom
it was like in the middle of night she
fell down and they realized like she was
in shock so he called the cops he said
last thing that was at whatever midnight
12:45 and they took her away and then he
passed away at the hospital mmm I got a
call him yet and stuff I'm so sorry
about that I didn't know that um let me
see her was she an actress she's a
writer director did some movies learn
more Shaolin together
yeah it's a big time writer you only
watch his uh his podcast he talks about
it he's like you I finally found someone
I connected with and we'd write her half
it's like such a shame such a shame
she's a smoke show too man she was mad
she looked at 54
well that's very son really really super
pretty damn it yeah mark was like I
finally found love I never had it before
such a shame that's heartbreaking the
years I priced him be doing this podcast
but this is this all I know how to deal
with grieving so that's why I'm doing it
ah yeah man I guess she came on years
ago on his podcast and I've never met
before and she was friends with his
ex-wife so he's always a little like
didn't be about bring her on and then he
brought her on and he said there's she
was married at the time he had a
girlfriend but he said there's ass weird
instant connection between them like
Ryder went right away like instant love
you think you're so strange and then she
got divorced he separates girl they got
together mmm so sad man Wow I know such
a bummer
it's so weird with death because all you
can do is say I'm sorry you know I'm
just kind of yeah yeah I don't know you
know she had a kid too I don't know how
old he is but a blood disorder ain't
that a [ __ ] yeah yep feel for mark man
I love mark man what I realize that
every once in a while I'll get a an ear
ache the top of my head will
hurt at the same time and yeah and and
one side of my throat will [ __ ] be
killing it right the tumor yeah so uh
that happens to be periodically it
happened to me like also not be like
what the [ __ ] and then do you know what
it is
it's eggplant what it's eggplant
if I eat Brazil nuts or eggplants you're
allergic to it I'm [ __ ]
oh my whole I thought you would say you
know what it is well let me an ice cream
it's a brain freak no like three days
really yeah my ear ear swells up my hold
on you weren't always like that really
put my mouth you just know oh you know I
think I was and I didn't realize what
was happening it's the weirdest [ __ ]
thing
are you are you allergic to you think
that um I have very mild allergies to
stuff like pollen me too and like um fur
that's about it I'm allergic to cats and
grass are you grass you grass everybody
is there anybody who can roll on grass
without a shirt on only kids can really
do as you get older you get itchy are
you allergic to anything chin just that
nice and supplement I took once member I
told you a nice and doesn't everybody
okay but why did you take that again
nice and that's a good for your brain oh
like it's a nice causes a flush it a you
because they want that flush what it
lasted for over a month and it made you
look super flabby and fat to him my body
was just weird nice yeah no it was it
wasn't it does something to the blood
vessels yeah so you're my huge love
house for a while and redness did not go
with fur yeah also eating a shitload of
ice cream and cake but also yeah when
you put nice on entire apple pie sitting
and you do that constantly
yes that's gonna cause love handles I
got a text from Julia and he goes I'm
getting a Ferrari [ __ ] you who did it
for you are well you know cuz I had
fries I know for I love Ferraris and he
the one he's looking at and I have my
guy grant shot to Greg who's my car guy
so I just connected him I sent him a
bunch I was like this she told me what
he wants pay so I said them a few and
it's work Bronco I'm into that Ford
Bronco not
or you pup now imagine rings I'd like to
get it yes bring up that Ford Bronco
well your is it 2021 oh yeah type in
2020 new for brothers that should I get
the two-door or the I need a truck for
my you know for my junk here my box made
of stainless hunting gear Prius but I
don't know no right there right there
that's it
your Papa's getting an all-white putting
black rims on it that's a great looking
truck I'm getting that [ __ ] you Brad for
you do ya this ridiculous yeah no I
wouldn't hold on not that go back to
that green one so back to that green one
is actually saying I can't where you
saying I can't drive be careful now
I can't drive that [ __ ] green Ford
Bronco [ __ ] are you gonna do yeah
yeah bring up the two-door yes what I'm
getting to do it you know you're gonna
do what you and jump into my backseat
you know suck your thumb with the sure
no I'm not gonna take the top down yes
like I need I need gear I need my German
Shepherds I need my guns need my
crossbow I need a lot of my gear they do
that's so good for my [ __ ] gear when
I get oh that's a prototype hmm gorgey
if it is the best what before hit it out
of the park with this their Mustangs do
too now but they hit out of the park
because they went oh you guys are there
that's still go back there that's from
the Ford plant that's a leaked photo of
the fort oh that's how it's that's the
[ __ ] Bronco dude I step forward I'm
gonna get it white sand we call juice
and I'm putting them black rims on it
dude me white Broncos LA how about that
one I can have one of these I can have
that why not
not for you dude I'm young when I get my
eyes done I'm gonna look like I'm 35 all
right we done my eyes don't go dude your
eyes done you know what what 2021 hey I
got good news I get bad news what bad
news is you're getting elective surgery
kind of lame yeah that's good news is if
your eyes do get better I might like let
you in the thick boy by club Oh does
your face look into it yeah you know but
are we saying Eddie's been right the
whole time like like it might be that
Eddie Bravo actually was on to something
here Eddie Bravo and Tim Dylan got it
nailed
I remember when Eddie liked it first off
the last fire the last fight companion
the best one ever
Eddie was never been more insane every
one of you trying to regulate
that insane sparkplug separately the bad
get to go yeah well your help do that
yeah but I were a long time ago like a
but maybe three or four months ago like
right when the concerns about the
lockdown first happens so distracted by
your shoulders Eddie said something so
that your innate actually thick muscular
kid I'm gonna have my hands full when we
rolled it oh my hands full better
believe it yeah but your neck full my
[ __ ] oh but your legs look eminently
you know [ __ ] take down a bowl but
keep going and you said something like
beginning of this this whole thing it
that did I always stuck with mean he
said imagine like you have a friend
instead like in a coma
he's in a coma right he wakes up right
now and he goes wait the [ __ ] the
Major League Baseball and the NFL's
[ __ ] clothes and there's no [ __ ]
NFL know any section okay so so there's
millions of people dead right and you're
like no no there's wait wait yeah so
then no one's filming any shows and the
[ __ ] businesses are all closed so
like it's 90 percent that people have it
right no like like like no like 12
percent yeah you know those latest under
74 years old with no morbidities you
have a ninety-nine point eight percent
chance of being 100 percent fine yeah
you're not gonna die yeah ninety-nine
point eight percent but a little more
than that like that's [ __ ] us there
that's true in a lot of regards I'm some
of the best radio people are not these
studied broadcasters they're like
they're like like average a lot of
allotted like AB former cops former
military look at Corolla Corolla is in
my opinion in the top 10 greatest of all
time that's fair and Corolla got on
radio because he was Jimmy Kimmel's
boxing trainer for a celebrity button if
it wasn't for that weird [ __ ] H
happen chance meeting when were that
well Jimmy was jimmy kimmel was the
sports Kevin and bean about 20 years ago
he was that was I don't know that Jimmy
was a radio guy and he got in a in a
on-air fight with another staff member
at K rock and
so they're like fine let's it we're
gonna settle this in the ring and we're
gonna get we're gonna sell tickets it'll
be great
so Kimmel goes out and gets a trainer
this other guy goes out and gets a
trainer Kimball gets Corolla who
happened to be listening and he says I'm
gonna drive down to Kay rock and I'm
gonna offer my services up starts
training Kimmel for this thing and then
after a while Jimmy comes back on the
air he's like you guys my boxing
trainers one of the way to get him on
the air I had analyzed they started
doing these characters on Kevin and bean
and next thing you know he goes the love
line and boom and that's so fine because
it's clear yes Adam brought something
that the the 95% of guys in talk radio
are either political dudes who are
stuffy or form of frat guys that are
like I'm the wild and crazy morning guy
or they're mimicking people that they
know of so there's it's all it all kind
of sounds the same and and and Corolla
brings this incredibly new blue-collar
regular guy you know ethic on top of his
ridiculous acerbic wit but he brought
something different amazing my point is
I didn't know that